is this a sandwich how about this for
this the interest well it depends it's
actually surprisingly complicated
jurisdiction scheme that's Neil fortune
he did professor of food law
he wrote the book on it literally just
what a sandwich is is actually defined
by the government
federally it's the USDA and the FDA
defining something matters because it
changes how it's inspected and regulated
the hotdog is regulated by USDA but a
hotdog on a bun is regulated by FDA a
sandwich doesn't have actually a strict
legal definition it's more than the
common term that can lead to some heated
arguments by sandwich parents according
to the USDA the hotdog is not a sandwich
but the dictionary says it is and so
does the state of New York
Mirek is pretty inclusive on the
sandwich question hi I'm David Greco
this is Mike's deli in the real Little
Italy of the Bronx our list of
sandwiches is at least fifteen
sandwiches we have the Bronx Tale the
Michelangelo Sophie Lorenz the Raging
Bull the Yankee big boy come on I'll
make you one special that's the New York
sandwich according to the state's
Department of Taxation and Finance not
only is a hot dog a sandwich but so is a
burrito that's because the burrito
counts as a wrap which in New York is a
sandwich okay so what about this it
looks and acts like a family
it's an ice-cream sandwiches sandwiches
I would say an ice-cream sandwich is a
fanciful name rather than an actual use
of the word sandwich in the traditional
sense fanciful name
delicious sandwich the USDA disagree
what do they know however sandwiches
define we know that there are all kinds
of delicious people is its well simpler
and much more complicated than it looks
on the circle thanks
[Music]